that was totally different than i
expected all right haunting a blind man
i actually got a few requests to review
haunting a blind manner among my october
movie review extravaganza uh the people
who requested it did you watch haunt it
well
probably not guess that's why someone
would want a review yeah much different
not really a haunting horror type
scenario at all it's it's a love story
however it still does have compelling
characters that i got attached to an
interesting setting and the intrigue
that kept me coming back for more i mean
it's really good so i want to talk about
it not gonna wear the halloween eyes
because like i
said it doesn't feel right here and just
so you know right here gonna give you a
spoiler warning i'm not gonna go into
details i'm not gonna detail the
spoilers this isn't a spoiler video or
anything
but it is a video in which i'm gonna fly
a little closer to the sun than i
usually would but i feel like i have to
to talk about it so there you go there's
my disclaimer because this is kind of
how it went down
all right some creepy imagery in the
background the first couple episodes but
it's playing the long game we've got
nine episodes we'll see how it goes
all right so it's more of a
psychological thriller than an actual
haunting show i mean it has spirits in
it but it's concentrating on the
psychological element
i see oh it's romance
is unexpected i don't even know how i'm
going to talk about the show without
bringing up some things that people are
going to consider spoilers how am i
going to do it so hunting a blind manor
is the new
netflix haunting mini-series the last
one was haunting of hill house not gonna
lie
i haven't seen it i sat down to watch it
but it was during the daytime and my
windows are behind me so i was like all
right let's watch the haunting of hill
house
with that window glare that looks like
this yeah
well okay maybe i'll come back tonight
then the adhd kicked in and
i just never got back to i think i was
slug i'll watch it in october
all right so haunting a blind manner so
it starts out takes place in the 80s and
this american girl
is over in the uk she running from
something yeah probably
running from what elijah wood from sin
city of course so she's gonna be a nanny
to this family by family i mean a couple
of kids and some people who work in the
house and it's actually kind of executed
it starts out carla cagino
is telling the story of the haunting of
blind manner you know think princess
bride
but with some spirits first of all the
acting all top notch of the regulars in
this mini series
everyone did a great job even the kids
you know how it is sometimes you gotta
give a little for kid acting you're like
okay but they'll grow no i thought the
kids were great even retrospectively you
know at the end you have all the answers
so you look
back and you think oh okay this was what
was actually going on in those first
episodes you look back and
the kids are even better and that
intrigue is definitely there but it's in
a different tone than you thought it was
it's more complex than this poltergeist
who just kind of prowls the hallways
that night it's it's a story about human
connection
it's not just the relationships when i
say relationship you think romantic
relationship
right natural and that is in here and
they're really compelling great
relationships but it's not just that
one of the most endearing relationships
in this entire show are two people who
never hooked up
they never hooked up but you feel the
love to their core
but you know the thing i loved about
blind man or mo i think it's about
episode
five you know you kind of have to give
this show
to episode five i think it was episode
five you gotta give it a few episodes to
get to that episode
where it's it's the most important
thread just going right through and it
brings it all together it attaches
everything you're like oh okay
it's this kind of show and it's such an
interesting and compelling episode
and it sets the stage for the entire
show going forward
but also the entire show looking back
because i realized the show was doing
something that i don't think i had
experienced not to this degree
and it's the main reason i really felt
compelled to talk about it here
it goes out of its way to show the
element of a haunted house
through the spirit's perspective no i'm
not saying everyone in the show is dead
and that's where the psychological
thriller element came
in you know we've seen haunting stories
from human beings in the house and you
still see that
here right out of breath for a second
sorry but at a point this show is like
hey
ghosts are people too or were point is
their characters let's make the spirits
characters and i really dug that because
the execution
that they do for that i i hadn't
experienced that to this degree what's
it like being a spirit what's it like
being trapped in these mental loops that
sometimes you break out of what's it
like just
going through motions not knowing you're
doing it what does this haunting
scenario look
like from the spirit do they see the
same thing we see
maybe not and i really dug that that
that's the hook right there that's when
i was like
oh amazing without that it would have
been an
interesting love story sure and it was
an interesting love story or a family
story
which if you look at some of the great
haunting movies
throughout history or the haunting
stories they are family stories so this
carries that tradition i just i found
something else with this that i hadn't
found before
i don't feel bad addressing that here
because the show actually tells me to
address it at the very end it all wraps
up carla cagino's telling the story and
someone was like
you lied you said it was a ghost story
it's a love story and she was like feel
free to make that correction if you ever
tell the story so here i am making that
correction and i've seen marketing kind
of like this before you know the whole
like oh it's a horror movie
it's really not though the two that i
think of are m night shyamalan's the
village
and crimson peak which were they were
romance stories there were romance
stories that were pitched as horror
because someone at the executive level
someone at the studio level was like um
so it can be marketed as horror right
yeah that's what we're gonna do
uh whatever by the time they're pissed
we already have their money over some
other movies i've seen that had
the miss marketing thing going on you
feel like that marketing scheme
began after post-production to get
people to watch it with hunting a blind
manner i feel like
that was planned before brief production
just
as part of the execution some
philosophical you see love stories and
ghost stories they're the same they even
say as much at the end of this movie
it's
basically a big epic troll move but one
that does
pay off because the characters were
compelling the characters were
interesting i got attached to them and
the premise itself had a hook that just
sucked me in because it's just
it's damn compelling stuff when you look
at it from that perspective but still
anyone turning on the haunting of bly
manor for some
solid halloween haunting scares because
it's called
the haunting of bly manor and it came on
netflix
in october anyone coming looking for
that might feel bored disappointed or
maybe a little pissed it might feel lied
to so just know what you're getting into
with this so all this is a really long
roundabout way of saying hey give it a
few episodes that's
again another way of saying give it a
few hours give it about the length of
a trilogy of other movies and if it
doesn't hook you by then it just seems
like a big investment but that's what
happened with me but
by the end i was glad i stuck it out the
second to the last episode i was like
this is a complete throwaway episode i
don't care
and then by the end i was like nah that
was pretty awesome or is it the haunting
of bly men or have you seen it why
should you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you